bonjour je viens qu'un commentaire
bonjour
coraline agents convivialité à manger
pour leur premier séjour grand air
claudine et julie découvre le charme de
cette maison d'accueil la case grand air
peut accueillir une vingtaine de
personnes en pension complète les
familles aidant aidé bénéficier ici d'un
cadre reposant et d'activités qui
constitue une réelle solution innovante
en matière de répit lakhal grand-père
principalement c'est un lieu déjà de
rencontres et de ressources pour les
personnes c'est vraiment apporter à
temps de détente
ce qui est visé un temps de détente
sadia pour que les personnes puissent
prendre le temps pour elle pour pouvoir
mieux aider leur idée est aussi attendue
des chances de rencontres de
l'information et de la formation pour
les aidants ici tout est propice à la
détente
un jardin de 2000 m² une salle commune
pour tous les invités et des chambres
spacieuses claudine et julie rencontre
sur le site d'autres familles des dans
un moment d échange d' écoute et de
compréhension ou chacun évoque la
difficulté du quotidien la nuit comme la
joignez il fallait veiller 24h 24 donc
me a river pu m'arrêter trop tout seul
donc là ici moi pour cette année moi je
veux profiter du répit aux portes pour
briser cette solitude
les aidants sont accompagnés par du
personnel qualifié il participe
notamment à des entretiens individuels
ou à des groupes de parole animés par un
psychologue et une assistante sociale
comme ça on se parle entre nous on sait
ce qui se passe chez les autres
après on prend enfin un choix on prend
ce qui est bon lait ce qui est mauvais
et ça nous sert beaucoup pour nous à la
maison
ben là je me suis repris
j'ai croisé pris confiance en moi même
ma fille je me suis ressourcé dis donc
je suis pas tout seul il y avait ce
serait pure power
ce dispositif innovant et complémentaire
à la politique du département de la
réunion pour le maintien à domicile des
personnes âgées dépendantes ou porteuses
de handicap
la journée se termine et notre groupe
profite d'une séance de relaxation